Steph and klay they're not settling just  for jump shots taking the ball off the  crumble here and a page out of Houston's  notebook in this throughout these  playoffs if it's Steph Curry Damian  Lillard guys taking 27 great defense by  rivers is better offered by curry heart  step back free James Hart Martin tonight  three of seven Thompson's defense there  [Music]  [Applause]  in his career  dances with the basketball let's step  back and he just lures you into this you  think you can cloak  [Applause]  triple here's the shot and watch the  follow-through to the side of the head  there  of draymond Green again the screen and  now he's got Thompson on Houston has not  missed the four shots they've taken a  three by James Martin for the MVP a  little dance a little shot creates the  space  right by loony again and collapsed the  defense step 3  [Applause]  look at this  he gets the mismatch that he wants get  some leaning step back